mano guruhi була внесена зимі треба
конституції за годину ти не правосуддя
даєте сніг за почин ідеї тайці Ерік
будуть початковою для ланки суднової
системи
новий верховний суд за місцем 3 вищих
спеціалізованих судів чи то нинішнього
верховним судом моїм буде ворони
повністю новий верховний суд уже до 30
Борис не обманюється завершить і конкурс
на 120 посад
у верховному судимий ти біляша частини на
таких масштабах заміщення судді вид
буває елітних перейшов європе
криптограф більш верховний і судимий
може стати і начхати не адвокати
інакшість та правнуки антикорупційні
суди розчинення ви кроку
антикорупційного суду потрібно у крему
і закони б усе вироблено ніби
спеціалізовані антикорупційної
прокуратури буде малоефективним
нинішній долях цих виплат як і вид
виртуса будь у розріз для корупції
високо пасодобль і легше законів дайсі у
квали тупарі щипало вигніть уроку
жест нас тут ногу антикора бти не суди
зможе забрати його тем у тому шлюбі та
політичної волі на думку експерти
арені мінті ногу пакету реформ
романо-кун біди ладаном а гаїті проти
всередині такі варіант закону які б
дозволяв і перебрати і лояльних судді
цьому грамотності треба ти снуд і на
владу де створи низ правді на золочених
антикорупційних судить суд присяжних
формально інститут присяжних в Україні
млн і шоу розряді кримінальних довідка
вирізаному виглядаємо теж вам про вахані
довели до влади і судимо за промені
неграмотністю було ефективним і за
право Дженні класичної моделі журі
присяжних у жити уроку можна створ цієї
закон про давши чого з новим припинити не за
менше черевань корупції закривав гус
подільських судах від уникнути довіри
інвесторів до української системи
правосуддя стрибати не в канавці перервати
йому до нас сизо можете проти ти вижив
першому кварталі тих уроку теж снігу
watchme там і право вибору сорту ти сюди
дріжджам навику навчу служби а буду
приватного ви до нігтів
конкуренції по ви нас менше ти
корупцію нині держава монополісту ти
сфері державних ви до нас завжди vista
чаю без хабарі мало хто барикаду з
правому ревниво каналі судових рішень не
задавили
електронний суд український суду
орієнтовані на спробувати тлумачення
це пресують місці без посередників судимий
по три безміни процесуальні за законом
дарства ще було беляші якнайшвидше
для електронного судом вона найкраща онлайн
оплату суднового збору тоді кількість інших
процедур в електронному виглядаємо з
законом очко що і відбувається рішення
справ з менших навантажень на судимий
за крима механізм електронного суднового
покаравши